kurfürstenstraße auf berlins
bekanntesten straßenstrich gehen die
geschäfte weiter trotz corona
doch weil die sexkinos ringsum zu haben
bleibt nur der gang ins öko klo wenn mal
ein kunde auftaucht manch einer war
vorher hamstern klopapier gerhard
schönborn berät frauen die auf der
kurfürstenstraße arbeiten er macht sich
sorgen
also der kampf um das geld ist für die
frauen natürlich verschärfter die frauen
sind auch mehr den männern ausgeliefert
weil sie auf das geld noch mehr
angewiesen sind als vorher schon und
damit ändert sich natürlich auch das was
sie machen oder machen müssen
eine rumänen die seit jahren in berlin
arbeitet erzählt wie sich das geschäft
in der korona krise verändert hat viele
kunden haben angst die straße ist jetzt
immer leer
das geschäft ist kaputt trotz der
quarantäne gehen die mädchen arbeiten
für 10 euro ich will das nicht für zehn
euro
ja viele machen es auch ohne gummi wie
viele frauen schätzen sie sind gerade
auf der straße unterwegs
80-100 nach wie vor viele aber wofür
wenn es keine arbeit gibt alles steht
still
kommen neue frauen dazu jetzt ja einige
sind dazugekommen für frauen wie sie war
das beratungs kaffee immer ein
rückzugsort
jetzt soll es geschlossen werden wegen
corona sowie viele hilfsangebote für
prostituierte medizinische versorgung
also gerade für frauen ohne
krankenversicherung aachener straße
geschlossen und es geht so weiter über
über beratungsstellen
leider kann man hygiene einrichtungen
und selbst dusche mobil für die frauen
geschlossen das heißt die möglichkeiten
die es bisher noch gab für die frauen
die minimieren sich auf ganz wenige und
wahrscheinlich sind sie da auch schon
sage ich mal zu spät weil die voll sind
und ausgelastet von daher wird sich die
situation für die die jetzt in not sind
und hilfe brauchen immens verschärfen
schönborn befürchtet bald könnten noch
mehr frauen auf der straße stehen denn
alle bordelle wurden geschlossen
[Musik]
busbetreiber aurel johannes marx auf dem
weg in seinen laden
[Musik]
wir befinden uns ist hier in meiner
prostitutionsstätten sprich im bordell
lankwitzer 7
freitag 20 uhr 30 normalerweise tobt
hier das leben hier sitzen jede menge
sex worker und warten auf kundschaft und
hier in den zimmern
während normalerweise kunden die sich
ihr geld ein bisschen spaß kaufen
manchmal sind die fragen jetzt die
frauen sitzen alle in wohnungen von uns
zumindest die nicht nach hause kommen
und hoffen dass irgendwann die ukraine
wieder haft macht und was andere länder
wieder aufmachen solange versuche ich
jetzt erstmal so weit wie es geht
die frauen zu finanzieren
bordellbetreiber marx sagt seine
geschäfte laufen schlecht die der frauen
auch wie lange das durchzuhalten sei
offen
im internet finden wir zahlreiche
kontaktanzeigen prostituierte auf
kundensuche wir chatten eine frau an
woher kommst du du bist nach hier trotz
corona ich habe kein geld und auch um
ganz so fahren wenn ich geld mache fahre
ich rüber wo bist du im hotel
ich habe kein geld für ein festes zimmer
der betreiber weiß auch in der korona
krise kaufen männer sex nicht mehr im
bordell sondern dort wo die frauen
wohnen
das kann man denen auch gar nicht übel
nehmen wenn die nur noch ein profi in
der tasche haben und da hinten der
supermarkt weiterhin geld haben will
müssen sie ja irgendwas machen um an
geld heranzukommen und dann ist es im
zweifel in einer privatwohnung immer
noch besser als ich in die
kurfürstenstraße zu stellen und sich
daran schnupfen zu holen
auf der kurfürstenstraße geht es für
viele frauen ums tägliche überleben
sowie für die bulgaren christo ihre
notunterkunft wurde geschlossen
ich schlafe jetzt auf der straße im park
viele leute viele frauen schlafen auf
der straße und schlafen jetzt immer mehr
frauen auf der straße
wie viele frauen schon obdachlos sind
ist schwer zu sagen wahrscheinlich
einige hundert puff betreiber marx
fordert vom staat hilfsangebote
schließlich sei auch sein bordell ein
wirtschaftsunternehmen das nichts zu
verschenken hat ein zwei drei wochen
mittragen wird sicherlich funktionieren
aber das ganze jetzt über 1 23 monate
mitzutragen
dann greift er richtig die korona krise
wie schwer sie ihn trifft unklar
fest steht viele frauen sind ohne hilfe
[Musik]